da quando sono tornato dalle vacanze non
solo più lo stesso ogni piccolo gesto mi
ricorda solo tutto ciò che ho perso
l'aria salubre del sole che stimolava la
mia melanina tutto quello che mi
circonda ha perso il suo colore ma ciò
che mi manca di più sono i sapori gli
arancini e la salsa tzatziki le
melanzane fritte darà noi ce li giudica
il terzo giorno quando gesù risuscita
passo ogni giorno alla ricerca di
maurice taylor qualcosa che mi permetta
di uscire dal baratro in cui mi trovo
sentire le mie papille almeno per
un'ultima volta di nuovo vive
ciao ragazzi bedonia di una puntata di
cucina puntata oggi per una ricetta che
c'è stata consigliata su instagram da
marco quindi sappiate che se non mi
piacerà potete andare insultare lui e
non di un periodo dovreste insultare che
gianmarco perché appena abbiamo visto
questo video siamo impazziti sta
parlando di una spugna commestibile con
tanto di sapone andiamo avanti
se sei la mia questa montatura una
facciata una vetrata che non ho chiesto
loro il più forte non è stato fisico ha
fatto male al loro covi di tutta la
gente si è portata che mi ha guardato il
tavolo ma fatto ciao guglielmo per fare
la spugna commestibile avremo bisogno di
140 grammi di farina 120 g di zucchero 3
uova 135 grammi di burro succo e scorza
di un limone zita con un pizzico di sale
mezzo cucchiaio di lievito in polvere un
quarto di cucchiaio di estratto di
vaniglia e al secchione
venerdì è infine colorante alimentare
allora pratica presupposto e sono molto
gasato all'idea di fare questa torta
perché perché l'idea di mangiarmi una
spugna avendo in casa se se viene fatta
bene non ti casa moltissimo perfetto una
un'esterna sincerità di gianmarco
guardate pensando a dalle troppe come
scary movie si è scusata pensare ai miei
comunque volevo dire quello che sento
arrivata questa ricetta infobox vi
lasciamo il video comunque originale
un'ora di quella il giusto metodo di
paragone tutti conoscono quella tutti
conoscono quella però potevamo metterli
a confronto barra potevano per renderlo
una spugna e mangiarci ritenere poi
quella meno dovranno stare il 70 a
cucinare e anche momenti e prima cosa
prendiamo il burro morbido mi raccomando
e lo tagliamo a pezzetti one teach
zucchero e infine zucchero la scorza di
un limone
mi raccomando ragazzi ogni volta che
usate la buccia di limoni arance
sciacquateli perché non sapete cosa ci
hanno messo sopra ma cosa c'e dentro a
questa birra in tempo cioè è la mia
delusione spatola
a questo punto aggiungiamo l'estratto di
vaniglia
amalgamiamo il tutto calcolo è questa
che se avevate in una torta limon osava
niglio zza apriamo le uova mi raccomando
un tuorlo alla volta non esser lotto 1 1
invece sembrano viscere un po coltello
in realtà quello che lei dice che è
normale che un pochino per via del
limone faccia ed l'ing krasic romitino
da fruire di lei stesa usando mela
attrezzo ricordo all'aula il mattarello
e hai fatto la frittata con tutti i
sensi
cos'è prendere la ricetta siamo fregati
non pensavo che volesse così poco per
precipitare subito sperarlo si sono
disperato e sinceramente posso dirti un
amico non direbbe costruire se vabbè
scusa scusa scusa
ciao guglielmo chiudiamo un occhio e
andiamo avanti perché tu sai perché puoi
fare tutto perché sei anarchico si 1
rispetti le regole di oggi le sta
rispettando dall'inizio alla fine di
questo format ma gomiti non commentiamo
utilizzando vomitino cioè un passo a
sinistra
toni saar guglielmo besta anarchy uniamo
gli ingredienti secchi può solo
migliorare forse mai fatto un miracolo
peso di una cosa mi sembra poco a ora
spugna ci diciamo che il 7 per
pubblicato se deve fare ora fuori dalle
case limone ma no ma voci finiscono i
semi non c'è fine mi ha chiesto le dosi
dai limoni conterno del suo interno con
45 grammi ancora lepri diverse dalle
solite rumore è fatto piccolo seme
sbirro 45 esegui adesso velocissimi
ragazzi seguite mentre gli accada qui in
mezzo chilo ma la l'estratto di vaniglia
bisogna cioè solo quando bara lode non
l'ho ripreso allora si chiede di preso
no è veramente un altro pianeta
ma segua della costa quando spremuto
questo tubetto l'ha ripreso gianmarco
perché tu hai accesso e quando ho
ripreso a vedere il momento in cui viene
spremuto questo betto ti prego no qua
sotto
fatevi curare 570 grammi un terzo di 575
molto sempre di vedere 180 circa marco
poi faceva dark e 570 199 18690 da 570
meno 190 a 280 10380 quindi giuste e tre
in tre pezzi da 190 abbiamo quindi due
terzi e un terzo i due terzi prendiamo
il colorante giallo il pensiero di
saranno abbiamo messo alzare
importantissimo esalta il sapore meglio
adesso o mamma mia ha messo due terzi in
quello piccolo pezzo in quel libro il
romanzo emozionante ragazzi ma così poco
se arriviamo bene il gioco ce l'abbiamo
e anzi vi dirò di più direi di iniziare
infornarlo mentre lavoriamo al colore
dell'altro 15 17 minuti in 160 gradi
[Musica]
e santo è la cosa migliore sia bagnarla
dicono le voci che ha nella testa allora
scrivono sempre perché così tiene meglio
la forma mettiamo un composto nella
teglia poi il muro perché se viene una
spugnetta fra 6 deludente espugna
potrebbero uscire seppure sono numeri
che dio ce la mandi buona
adesso cosa difficile sarà creare il
verde perché non c'è la giusta
supermercato c'era il blu è lo bello
tutti i 90 ne ha messi lo sai colletto
blu è il colore alimentari nel 2020 e
diventano verde acqua perchè la pasta è
già l'esatto io ci avevo già pensato che
potessero succede ma sme ea raggiungere
pochissimo cioccolato amaro ma guardati
e imparati dove andare un po più bassa
padovana porcheria ottenuto qualche
minuto in più è venuta perfetta
catenaccio un attimo queen pero ci
aggiungiamo il composto questo bello
fino a ricorda mufasa simba una spatola
per livellare 12 minuti e in bocca al
lupo
angelo da perfetta chi è dio utilizzo un
pochino di car meno salato e stendere un
velo in modo attaccare le due parti
insieme
riuscirà a incollarsi in serie pc così
sono soddisfatto prendo questo è il mio
letto sopra c'è depotenziato cioè il
potenziale infatti sono molto gasato
coltello a seghetti no andiamo a
prendere più palo e sottile a parte
sopra anche perché se poi vedete nel
momento in cui inizia a tagliarlo riveli
una texture un pochino più sporca si sia
più grezza a questo punto
perché più belle in assoluto creiamo le
spugne stavolta coltello invece è
perfetto e andiamo prima a rifilare
bordi è uscita bella ragazza venuta fin
a questa qui ragazzi ce la fate a parte
tanga temi su instagram se non è geniale
non da fare come scherzo ste cazzate qui
e divertenti sia spero sia buono a fine
pranzo tutti cina che adesso che sono ai
piatti e servi questo è geniale è
carinissima prima dell'assaggio
barbatrucco velocissimo prendiamo un
uovo e prendiamo solamente 8
il danno è aperto malissimo non è che si
è aperto un luogo malissimo se tu vr
trovare per fortuna ci si rompe le uova
le aprì l'addio e non parlavo al volo un
cucchiaio estratto di vaniglia una
piccola taricone coltello giallo un
pochino stop non nulla fruste
la cosa importante è quella di non
montarli troppo e prendere solamente la
spina sopra per fare effetto sapone dire
a questo punto di passare la sancho
panza
credo che sia il modo migliore per
riprendere questa stagione di cucina
buttata stupenda inutile eppure
essenziale
raga ma quante linea cioè ragazzini
parte rico controlla la forchetta va
bene approvata va bene ok pazzo la
presenza delle parti dei due posante dal
riscatto da casa prenderò gli avanzi di
enrico dandogli un insegnamento morale
spero in futuro aperto le da sanchez a
esser spugna il puglia è molto bella
devo dire grazie all 1 0 c è una spugna
con del sapone
anche se questo è diversa ed a quella
che ho visto prima un po più piccolina
rispetto alle spugne per lavare i piatti
a proposito ragazzi ormai sono dieci
video circa che ci dicono che lo sfondo
fa cagare maradiaga reed umano
lei scelti dei colori in famiglia quindi
lo so ci inventiamo qualcosa
vai spero che sia migliorata la
situazione l'aspetto è bellissimo non ci
siamo guglielmo è suggerisca aspetto è
bellissima quindi affetto ledare tipo un
8 ma il pensiero che io la devo a
mangiare in realtà barba in conflitto
con affetta da questa nota torna mia
quindi diciamo che de da un voto che va
tra l'otto e te li do un bell 8 se fosse
una torta e basta sarebbe pure un po a
cagare
ma ispirandosi all'immagine di una
spugna è spettacolare secondo me io do
10 bravo guglielmo questa volta sono con
te andiamo con l'assaggio io non sono un
amante del pan di spagna nel centro
fatto bene si è buono fatto da guglielmo
vediamo assaggio rehn dunque di sapone
mancherò sapone in mezzo fra l'altro i
[ __ ] che sul blues è buonissima e
proprio bona e rozzo un fan delle torte
troppo semplici senza creme senza cose
così
ma e saporitissimo e poi è così c'hai
molti ma per questo comunque palazzo e
poi anche caliamo al sapore do un sette
e mezzo bello pieno morta otto e mezzo
solo resetto in mezzo perché gradevole
consente di essa
odore freschissimo e buonissimo odore
discreto 70 rom anche in parte di questo
noi motore da spugna non è proprio
esaltante molto buono fresco ragazzi
sede e mezzo sei e mezzo quanto pagherei
per questa torta è una casa da fare
molto appariscente ma in realtà inerenti
sono semplicissimi quindi 5 euro 7 euro
perché le immagini non posso così un
pacchetto uso che ti dà sta roba magari
dentro esporta sapone
anche io lo vedo in un ristorante di
lusso 67 euro di evitare volentieri anzi
se mi scrivessero spugna commestibile
per lavare i piatti arriverei anche a 8
allora accanto avessi un dispenser tipo
per i saponi liquidi ma carino lo
pagherei anche 10 euro questa chiama che
ci metti sopra sempre cruze e c'è il
sapone
l'imam bello bello grazie ragazzi se
volete la fine di questo video come
sempre se volete replicare questa torta
ve lo consiglio questa volta attacca
temi su instagram
iscrivetevi a questo canale 30 comma
nelle notifiche metteteci un bel paul
simon e soprattutto fateci sapere quali
altre ricette vi piacerebbe vedere
all'interno di cucina buttata un bacio
grande ci vediamo giovedì prossimo alle
ciao